damn that's crazy you got a song with
freddie gibbs and you never even met
this cat
yeah but i i don't know i always been a
fan like you know saying that [ __ ] was
like
i feel like i just talked about him and
i talked him up
let me see if i can get this
[ __ ] to answer his facetime real
quick
have you meet him right now
i have a feeling this [ __ ] was gonna
happen that's hard we were just with we
we just met drake together the other day
how was that
he's answering frederick
yeah what are you doing buddy
oh god damn why you always [ __ ] going
somewhere dog
what what island
okay hey look i'm i'm doing a podcast
with this kid named kenny mason
you have a song with him and he said he
never met you
just just uh turn your [ __ ] camera on
so you can say hi to this guy we're
we're filming right now so i'm trying to
do the introduction
all right all right this [ __ ]
going to hawaii
that's time just on the wheel
yeah like i just talked to this guy i
didn't mention i'm going away i'm like
probably just [ __ ] just like let's go
to hawaii
gangster gibbs you been hawaii yeah uh
maui
oh sorry now he's a vibe you've been
there i ain't never been no
go to maui bro that [ __ ] is uh it look
like hawaii out here
nah no no no no no no no
no no no no i just ain't seen [ __ ] this
[ __ ] out here
sucks i ain't gonna lie i got love from
california
the beaches and [ __ ] out here are trash
you if you want to go to like a beach
bro the beach was five we just went nah
go to [ __ ]
what is gibbs
the gmail.white edit that out
yo yo this guy's got the best gmail ever
that's [ __ ] crazy say hi to this guy
what's up gang what's going on
we're going on my way
i'm ready i'm in l.a now [ __ ] oh i can't
do that [ __ ] really
he said he's ready but he's going to
hawaii so you're going to have to do it
another time right
here i'm going to be all month he said
all right well have fun man in hawaii
and uh
you know do your best to uh i don't know
don't make the shade room while you're
out there is all i'm gonna say
just don't beat up any locals
all right i'm proud of you all right
we're gonna get back to this interview i
just wanted to
he said he never met you so
all right brother